ok let's get into audience questions for
the week first one today is from Sara
Sara says hey David you've talked about
making Election Day a holiday in the
United States and that town in Ohio
actually did it
what about mail-in ballots isn't that
actually overall a better system okay so
a couple yeah it's it this is a great
idea so let's go back to what we're
trying to do the idea is for more people
to vote right now you only have in
presidential elections roughly half the
country votes sometimes it's forty five
percent fifty five percent depending on
is that a midterm is at a particularly
interesting presidential election or
whatever else that's not great I as a
progressive want as much involvement
I want people I want the country to be
as involved as possible in the process
of selecting our leaders not voting is
not a neutral act in other words when
you don't vote you're not saying I have
no influence you're saying I'm going to
have an influence in that my vote will
not be there meaning everybody else's
vote now counts a little more and I am
choosing to just allow other people to
decide that has an impact and in general
the impact is making our elected
officials in total more conservative
than the people that they represent so
we want more people to vote that's what
I want I think that would be important
we've got all the voter suppression that
we're dealing with and then on the other
side of it there are ideas about how we
might increase voter turnout one idea is
you make Election Day a holiday that
could be keeping it on Tuesday it would
be hard in the unit in the United States
to move Election Day to a different day
but in other countries they have
election days on weekends a lot of
people work on weekends so again if you
don't make it a holiday you're still
going to sort of have an issue with
people who are not going to ask for the
time off to vote because yeah you can't
get fired for going to vote but if
you're an hourly worker you're just not
going to get paid so one idea is you
make Election Day a holiday and that
helps in one way a bigger idea is you
switch to mail-in ballots and people
doesn't matter whether you work on
weekends or weekdays or whether you work
second shift or first shift or whatever
else you have some period of time
many days a couple weeks depending on
how it's set up
to fill out and send in your ballot this
is good for a number of reasons
number one it expands it's no longer
just 8 a.m. to 6 p.m. or whatever the
voting hours are during which you can
vote so if that's what was holding you
back from voting it eliminates that it
eliminates the possibility of polling
place electioneering which is another
problem that we're dealing with it
eliminates the possibility of in-person
voter suppression people coming through
lines and saying inaccurate things about
what IDs are required or scaring people
off in in some other ways that we've
covered over the last many years on the
program you deal with the possibility of
voting machines in the moment not
working you send your ballot in you fill
it out you have time to review
candidates in all of that stuff although
where the ballot is received by mail it
could still be processed by a voting
machine that could have an issue so I
think that mail-in ballots is absolutely
a fantastic idea right now you have to
request an absentee ballot if you're
going to vote by mail it has to be
approved there are only certain reasons
why you're allowed to do it although the
the strictness with which that's applied
sort of varies from state to state so I
am absolutely and completely all for it
and think it would be much better than
Election Day simply being a holiday the
issues that exist with it are all issues
because of right-wing voter suppression
we actually saw it in Georgia in the
midterm election with the gubernatorial
race you can have slick workers election
campaign workers who decide to show up
at people's houses and say I'm here to
collect the ballots and people who are
unsure about what to do or maybe don't
realize that that's crazy that you've
got to mail it they might turn over
their ballot to someone who is claiming
to be an election official but is
actually just a partisan political
operative those are the types of
problems that can come up with mail-in
ballots but that's just an awareness
thing if we put in place vote by mail
you do an awareness campaign that says
do not hand your ballot to anyone do not
do anything other than sealing the
ballot usually you put it inside of
another sometimes you put it inside of
another envelope like there's two
envelopes sometimes there isn't and mail
it that's it don't hand it to anyone
drop it in a post-office drop it off at
the post office or in a mail slot or
whatever if you know your USPS worker
okay you hand it to them because they're
actually somebody that works for the
post office that is it and we could
solve that with an awareness campaign so
I'm totally for mailing ballots I'm not
against making Election Day a holiday
but I think mail-in ballots would be
fantastic